this is the former leader of the Liberal
Democrats the right honourable Walter
Mingus Campbell
he's the MP for North East Fife and in
his youth he was an Olympic sprinter
holding the British record for the 100
meters I want to talk about his name
Walter Mingus Campbell Ming for short
most people who aren't Scottish will
look at that middle name and pronounce
it Menzies in fact a lot of people do
pronounce it that way so what's going on
here to find out we have to go back into
history our modern English alphabet
hasn't always looked like this it
evolved over time the full eh-2-zed that
we have today didn't settle down until
about the 18th century in 1011 a monk
called Bert Firth and I'm probably
mispronouncing that wrote down what he
considered to be the alphabet what we
would now call the old English Latin
alphabet in alphabetical order as part
of a manuscript now since England in
1011 had no mass communication this will
not be definitive it's an example of one
set of letters and ordering but he shows
pretty clearly the major differences
over a thousand years so let's handle
the letters that we all recognize first
I and J at this point in history are the
same letter they wouldn't split for
centuries if you've ever seen Indiana
Jones and the Last Crusade you'll
remember Sean Connery muttering about
your over starting with an i which does
raise the question of why there was a J
on that deathtrap but never mind
U and V are combined as well and there's
no W at all instead that harp-like glyph
the win was used for what
after the Normans invaded in the 12th
century the win would fall out of use
getting replaced with a double U which
became a W bird Firth included two
symbols for and in his alphabet actually
in his alphabet if you speaking in
Gaelic languages you may recognize the
second one it's still in use today in a
couple of places
then there's the win the were then the
thorn and the F used for sound last up
is the ash which represents a vowel
halfway between and now these letters
are still used in some European
languages Icelandic still has thorn and
ash what killed them all in English well
time for a start some of them just
dropped out of use and were replaced or
grew similar to other letters but
secondly there was the advent of movable
type in the printing press for example
presses imported from Germany didn't
have a thorn they did have a Y which as
the thorn hadid
or overtime in the British Isles was
considered close enough that's why to
this day we still see the old with a why
it's the last vestige of Thorne in
English still doesn't explain minister
well by middle english another letter
had popped up yo now this could
represent all sorts of sounds in English
but in Scots it generally represented
only a couple of things including the
yuh sound and yet again the printers
didn't have the right letters and their
boxes of movable type so they use the
closest thing they had as ed Mingus
became well still Mingus and a few
hundred years later here we are
some people switch the pronunciation
some didn't if you grew up in the UK
before the turn of the millennium you
will remember when John Menzies shops
were in every High Street but here's my
question has the English alphabet
stopped evolving now those was with
British or American keyboards I only
have 26 letters at our disposal and
typing anything else is enough of a pain
that most people don't bother when we
use all of those letters and only those
letters regularly and their design is
codified into every font on every
computer in the world could this still
be room for change or is this the last
alphabet the English will ever have